uh now let's do a quick review of uh
previous lecture lecture 18. so we
talked about uh pin photodiodes which
are used to detect uh basically the
light that is received by a lidar and we
talked about the physics of it so the
Pion photodiode it's like a regular
diode which is a PN Junction except
there is an extra
material in between the p and the n-type
semiconductors which is an undoped a
semiconductor called the intrinsic
material and that material is actually
uh the the photo sensitive part of the
of the pin diode so
as photons which are close to the band
Gap energy of the intrinsic material
get into the intrinsic region uh some of
them get absorbed as we said and they
generate a photo current and the photo
current uh in amps is given by the
responsibility of the pin photodiode
times the power of the incident
light basically that's uh that's hitting
the diode and we also talked about the
you know how you calculate the
responsibility there's a few factors
there's a reflectivity of the intrinsic
material there is uh basically the
absorption coefficient
and uh and there is uh so those together
basically give you the full Quantum
efficiency and then it can be converted
to the responsibility of the of the
device
then we started looking at the all
voltage current characteristics of the
the pin photodiode so it's important to
note that the devices is still a diode
right so yes it's a special type of
diode that is sensitive to photons and
generates a photocurrent but the full
response of the device is still
has the characteristics of a regular
diode and as you know a regular diode
the voltage current characteristic is
given by an exponential function so
that's given here so in this very simple
circuit we are applying a voltage VD
across our pin photodiode and the
current ID is going through it and the
the convention in analyzing electrical
circuits is always that current goes
from positive to the negative terminal
of the device so that's a positive
current so that ID uh is is given if it
was a regular diode it would just be
this exponential term which is I is uh
which we call the dark current times e
to the uh Elementary charge times the
voltage applied to the device divided by
the Bolten constant times the absolute
temperature minus one okay now because
this is a special diode there is an
additional term which is the photo
current that gets added uh to the to the
uh total total current why the negative
sign here again it's because of our
convention that we take ID to go from
the positive to the negative terminal
but the photo current as we saw goes in
the opposite direction so so that's why
we add the minus sign when we calculate
the total current now we said that uh
for for this to become useful for
sensing we are only interested in the
photo current part of this right
everything else is it's kind of like
noise or interference that that we don't
like it's not useful for sensing because
because it's
not there's no signal in here right this
is all just from the voltage that that's
being applied to the to the to the diode
so in order to basically eliminate this
term
uh what we do is that we apply a reverse
bias so negative make make the the v d
negative and that kind of if it's uh
negative enough basically this this
exponential term becomes almost uh
almost negligible almost zero and then
we get something where uh the the the
total current that is is uh going
through the the diode is just the sum of
the dark current and the photo current
and then that makes a proper you know
sensor there's one more reason uh uh why
reverse biasing helps us uh which as we
as we showed it increases the bandwidth
of the pin diode because it reduces The
Junction capacitance so there's two
reasons one is increased bandwidth the
other one is it makes ID almost be
proportional to the photo current which
is
um basically a good for sensing
questions
all right let's continue
so uh here is is basically a plot of the
voltage current characteristic of the of
the pin photodiode and you can kind of
break it into three regions there is uh
so so horizontal axis here is the the
voltage across the diode V sub D and the
vertical axis is the current that's
going through the device and
um the three regions is that there's the
forward bias regime also called the
photovoltaic regime where basically the
exponential term dominates because VD is
is positive and you get these very
non-linear curves basically so that part
is not useful for sensing for other
applications you might want to operate
in in that regime but not for sensing
then you have the reverse bias part
where V sub D is negative
right and that's called the
photoconductive regime and in that part
basically the exponential term is is is
is almost zero so what you get is your
ID
the total current is uh just basically
minus the dark negative the dark current
minus IP okay and uh so so
um basically it then varies linearly
with the incident power so it just
becomes uh the doctrine that is a
constant minus the responsivity times
times power okay and that's shown with
these multiple curves so each of these
curves is basically the IV
characteristic for a different amount of
incident Photon flux and that's this
error shows uh basically uh increased
Photon flux and when there is no Photon
flux in the negative bias regime you
just get the dark current so that's why
there's a non-zero ID and then as you
increase your Photon flux basically it
just linearly varies your ID linearly
varies with with the photon flux
and that's value
of the device and then beyond breakdown
voltage basically the device breaks down
not usually not in a it's it can recover
so it's not like you would fully destroy
the device usually okay except if you
apply a voltage Way Beyond breakdown but
you can go a little above or below
breakdown voltage and and you get then a
very non-linear response uh from from
the device and that's called basically
the geiger mode
so uh for sensing we are interested
basically in this part okay so this is
for sensing
specifically for for lidar cameras
things like that for photo sensing uh
that's that's the region we want to
operate in we want to be in the reverse
bias but uh the reverse part itself as
you can see uh you can kind of be in in
different areas uh so you can be kind of
in the mid
to high-ish reverse bias and if you're
in this region you get you know a a a
nice linear response from your your
device as it's shown by this curves but
you can also operate close to breakdown
voltages specifically you can you can
you can have a very high
um you know negative bias voltage close
to the breakdown and then the response
starts to become uh non-linear okay or
you can operate slightly uh uh beyond
the breakdown voltage and being the in
the geiger mode regime so what is the
what is the difference of of these
basically modes of operation so the
three regimes first we have uh or the
three basically modes of operation in
the in the reverse bias regime first is
the photo conductive regime or or region
so that's where as I said you have low
to medium reverse bias voltage and if
you are in that mode you get a
responsibility that is on the order of
one okay amps per watt
from the from a good photo diode okay it
can be slightly above slightly below I
mean the point that the range is usually
like somewhere between 0.8 to like 1.1
or so on the order of one uh but then
what's important is that the the current
ID varies linearly with the incident
Optical power so you get a linear
detector right linear in power not
linear in in amplitude of of of of the
field but linear in the optical power
okay
then you can uh further uh you know uh
uh uh increase the reverse bias so make
it more negative and then you get into
the non-linear regime so that's where
you have a very high reverse bias
voltage but you're just below breakdown
okay so you haven't quite gone past the
breakdown voltage
that mode of operation then the PD is
called an avalanche photodiode or an APD
okay what happens if you do that is that
you can get very high responsivity so
you can get responsivities of on the
order of a hundred due to a physical
effect which is called impact ionization
so in that sense it's a good thing for
sensing right you can make your
photodiode a lot more responsive to to
incident Photon flux but the trade-off
is uh the response becomes also very
non-linear right so then your ID the
current varies non-linearly with the
incident power because again if you go
to the previous slide you're you're in
in you know in in this region where the
responses starts to become very uh very
non-linear finally you can go beyond
breakdown and and operate in the geiger
mode uh basically and this is where your
reverse bias voltage is is uh beyond the
breakdown voltage of the device and then
in this mode of operation the PD is
called a single Photon Avalanche
photodiode or a spat okay
essentially in this regime you get
something like infinite responsibility
um but again the trade-off is so that
you can think of it as a good thing for
sensing it becomes extremely extremely
responsive to incident Photon flux to
the point that basically uh it's it's
like an on off switch for you so as soon
as it's even a single Photon hits the
detector it just triggers the maximum
current that it can possibly produce so
that's that's the Avalanche effect
basically uh and and from a single
Photon and if there's no Photon you
basically get nothing uh so so it
becomes extremely extreme only
non-linear in the in the geiger mode
regime now when it comes to lidars it
turns out you might ask okay so what's
what's the best choice for building a
lidar it turns out that all three modes
are used but it really depends on your
system architecture specifically the
waveforms that you send kind of
determine uh what what what mode of
operation in terms of biasing the
photodiode you want to be at so for
instance uh as as we'll see most lidars
are direct detection lighters which only
detect uh the the the
incident power of of of the pulses and
work with very simple waveforms so for
those they just want to apply a
threshold to the echo that they receive
and use that for time-of-flight
estimation they don't quite care about
the specifics of the waveform so they
want just maximum responsibility so
direct detection lidar they it's very
common for them to use APD or spats okay
because they don't quite care about the
waveforms but then you have more
sophisticated types of Lighters coherent
lidars which kind of like CW radar they
send like FM or PMA forms like chirps or
or ranging codes and as we know you need
to apply DSP to those waveforms to be
able to do a random velocity estimation
so for those types of a coherent liar
it's very important to have a linear
detector that does not distort the
waveform right so coherent lidar uses
operates in a photo conductive regime
because linearity matters so again it
not you should decide do you care for
linearity or do you care for sensitivity
and and then that determines how you
want to bias
okay so just to summarize uh reverse
biasing what it does for us if if you
have a negative V bias in the ID
response the voltage current response of
the device the exponential term is
almost zero so the current that's going
through the device becomes just the sum
of the dark current and the photo
current and if the dark current is a
small or Com or negligible compared to
the photocrine you can just say that
your your total current is almost equal
to the photo current which is just a
responsibility times the the incident
power okay so
um to get a nice linear response out of
a photodiode we need some external
circuitry that applies a constant
negative bias voltage for us so you want
to kind of hold your device
and by device I mean the photodiode at a
constant negative V bias and then
somehow measure the current that's going
through it and to do that to achieve
that you need some external circuitry
which is the biasing circuitry for you
this is sometimes this this uh vertical
line sometimes it's called the load line
so that's here how we're loading the
device and and by fixing a constant bias
voltage you basically get this vertical
load line and then the current as we
said is just proportional to the
incident power
we achieve this uh basically
um
or what type of circuitry do we need to
build to achieve a constant negative
bias voltage uh the the best type of
circuit that achieves this is called a
transimpedance amplifier or a TIA which
actually is a very very simple circuit
here's a kind of like in this let's look
at the picture together it's the ideal
version of it what the transimpedance
amplifier is is it's it's a high gain
op-amp operational amplifier which is
this device
and
the circuit is built by tying the
positive terminal of the pin diode to
the inverting input of the op amp and
then the negative terminal of the of the
photodiode is applied to our negative V
bias rail okay and the non-inverting
input of the op amp is grounded
and then there is some uh feedback
resistor that ties the inverting input
of the op-amp to the output okay so
let's see what what uh what happens
because
um these High Gain op-amps typically
have very high input impedance uh what
happens is that uh the the two inputs
are virtually at the same potential when
the op-amp operates so that means
because the the positive input is
grounded the negative one is also
virtually grounded held at you know a
very low potential and that means our
our diode is held at a constant volt uh
bias voltage right because both the
terminals are now at a constant voltage
positive side is grounded negative side
we are tying it to our negative V bias
okay so so this gives us the load line
that we want which is constant voltage
and uh another thing that the circuit
achieves is that all the current that is
generated in the uh pin diode it's going
to pass through the feedback resistor so
the current path is is basically like
that okay and by passing the current
through the feedback resistor we convert
it to a voltage which you can measure at
the output of the open
okay so your output voltage is basically
just the the the diet current times the
feedback resistance and uh in terms of
the incident Optical power it just
becomes minus the responsivity of the
diode times the feedback resistance
times the the optical power that's
incident on it so it's a very nice
simple you know circuit that achieves
exactly what we want it it gives us if
we can you can set a negative bias
voltage and it holds the pin diode at
that constant bias voltage also nicely
converts current to voltage for us so
this voltage can now you can feed it to
an ADC if you like
and digitize it
and then do DSP on it
okay so this circuit is basically
photons in
and electrons out
and the output it's it's a voltage type
output so it's very compatible with you
know adcs for for digitization now this
was the idea deal circuit in reality
it's a little more you know complex than
this so a more you know accurate model
of a transimpedance amplifier kind of
looks like this so here it's still you
know that the same architecture if you
will but if we have added a few
non-idealities to it to make the model
more complete first is that the well the
op-amps are not ideal devices so the
gain of the op-amp is it it has some
frequency dependency so so we have made
a instead of a constant gain a just a
function of frequency that's uh how
these circuits work and then as as we
talked last time these pin diodes have
some Junction capacitance right so the
correct small signal model of the diode
is is what we have put here so instead
of just the diode
basically we model it the small signal
model
is a current source which is producing a
current that is I sub D the current
through the diode in parallel to that
you're adding this parasitic capacitance
so C remember is the junction
capacitance
which as you know affects the bandwidth
of the device so this is a more complete
model of the diode that you're putting
in here also in practice
the feedback that is put in the in the
trans impedance amplifier it's not just
resistive some
capacitance is also added so that's not
parasitic capacitance that's a capacitor
that you know the the electrical
engineers design and add to the feedback
because it helps stabilizing the
response so it basically kills uh uh
resonances and oscillations at the
output you get a nicer wrist mask so you
can solve the circuit uh I'm not going
to go through all the details but it's a
simple even even by hand you can solve
it you just write down your kirchhoff's
voltage current equations and and solve
find the basically the frequency
response of it and here I'm defining the
frequency response h of omega as the
output I'm taking as as the voltage
output V out so this is V out of Omega
divided input you can take it as the
current or the the optical power I I
just decided to use the optical power as
the input but just remember that ID is
responsivity times P so you could also I
mean these two are just
scaled versions of each other you can
also Define your HSV out over ID
and you pretty much get the same thing
except I guess the r wouldn't be there
but here's Here's the the the full
solution
there's a lot in here but at the end of
the day it becomes a low pass filter
okay so low pass filter and note that
everything in this expression is known a
of Omega is the frequency response of
the op amp so whatever op amp is used
you can go to the data sheet and it
gives you what AF Omega is RF is the
feedback resistance R is the
responsibility of the photodiode you can
get that from the photodiode uh data
sheet C is the junction capacitance of
the photo that again you usually can
find that in the data sheet of the pin
diode or if you if you know the geometry
of the diode you can just calculate it
and CF is also a design parameter which
is the capacitance and the feedback uh
that that that you know so everything is
known you can plug it in and actually
you know plug everything in and and plot
the for instance the the impulse the
frequency response as a function of
frequency but the point is it it if it's
designed right it will be a low pass
filter if not that means there's there's
some design flaw but you know properly
designed Tia would have if you if you
look at the magnitude of HFF or h of
Omega let's make it Omega because the
note says Omega h of Omega as a function
of Omega it will be a low pass filter
with some cutoff frequency Omega zero
okay now to find your output voltage
from this once this is found it's easy
right so your V out
of T is just the inverse Fourier
transform
of H of Omega
h of
Omega
times P of Omega
and what is p of Omega P of Omega is the
Fourier transform
of the incident Optical
power okay so as easy as that if you
first plug everything in you find your H
and then you just
take the Fourier transform off P of T
which is the incident basically power as
a function of time and then filter that
so it's a filtering effect right this is
all we are doing here we're just
filtering p with the with the frequency
response of the Tia now it turns out
that again for well-designed
on TIA within the bandwidth the
magnitude of H is pretty constant so you
can call that h0 so if your P or the the
the fft of p is kind of like well within
the bandwidth of the device so for
instance if if this this one is p of
Omega so if it's well within the
bandwidth then the result of this you
know filtering effect just becomes a
scaling it just becomes h0 times P of t
um so again even in a in a in a
realistic case uh for a well-designed
TIA and an input signal that is within
the bandwidth of the Tia your output
voltage is just linearly
proportional to the incident power so
the linearity still holds even in a more
realistic case that's the point uh any
questions about tias
okay so let's continue so I think uh by
this point we basically finished uh all
the all the physics that that we needed
to learn about to understand lidars at a
system level so we talked about lasers
we talked about different ways of
Illuminating the scene we talked about
gaussian beams and the you know Optics
or lenses that help us collimate the
beams we talked about beam scanning and
we talked about photo detection so
physics done now we can talk about
system architecture for for lidars so
just just like
doors and sonar you can kind of do a
little taxonomy of of of lidar and
there's two main types of of lidar uh
that that that you can you can design uh
first is called the direct detection
lidar and this is very similar in in
principle to pulse Echo sonar
and pulse radar
it's very similar it's also called tof
or time of flight lidar in the industry
but this term is just technically
incorrect because all lidars measure
time of flight for ranging at the end of
the day but for some reason it's it's
very common to call Direct detection
lidar tof
what distinguishes tof lidar is that it
it uses just a single photo detector and
it detects just the received Optical
power
okay very important so direct detection
lidar only detects the power of the
incident
light or electromagnetic wave versus
this second type of Flagler which is
called coherent detection lidar or
coherent lidar it detects the full
electromagnetic field so it detects both
the amplitude and the phase of light
okay and it uses a a more complex module
at the receive site which is called a
coherent optical receiver we'll talk
more about it but coherent detection
lidar it's it's very similar in
principle to CW sonar
and CW radar like FMC wpmcw that that we
have seen
um
okay so
um a few more details so direct
detection lidar it it it it sends
basically
um short pulses periodically again
exactly like pulse radar
um some of them just just use very
simple pulses like pulses with gaussian
envelopes some other systems use more
more complex pulse shapes but because
these systems only care about the
received power that's all they measure
and they just want to apply a threshold
to calculate time of flight it's very
common for them to try to maximize their
sensitivity at the receiver so they use
apds or spats to improve sensitivity
okay because at the receiver all the
phase information is lost anyway so so
they just try to you know maximize the
sensitivity so they can see further out
and then ranging yeah it's it's mostly
done via a simple thresholding but in
principle they can also do match
filtering and because they only detect
the optical power essentially all the
phase information is lost at the
receiver and we know for instance phase
information contains the Doppler
frequency which can be used for velocity
estimation direct detection lidar cannot
do that so they cannot detect velocity
because they don't have the phase of the
signal at the receiver now coherent
lidar again it's exactly like CW radar
and sonar so they continuously transmit
waveforms to their CW systems they can
be fmcw or pmcw so they can for instance
send chips just like fmcw radar or these
ranging codes like pmcw radar
and they can do velocity estimation
because they have the full field so they
can recover Doppler frequency from the
phase of the received signal so that's a
that's a very important you know
characteristic of coherent light out in
addition to to range and DOA it also
gives you velocity now generally
speaking a coherent lidar can achieve a
much better performance so it's not just
that it gives you velocity and the
direct detection lighter doesn't but
even for range an SNR coherent can can
achieve a much better range because it
has much better SNR than direct
detection lighter there's a very simple
argument that can be made to kind of
justify why coherent achieves a better
SNR so direct detection lidar as we said
measures Optical power right so Optical
power is proportional to the square of
the electric field right as we know an
electric field
for instance if you look at the gaussian
wave approximation that we did electric
field is proportional to 1 over range
okay so that means the signal that a
direct detection lidar receives is
proportional to 1 over r squared or Norm
r squared which is where R is the the
round trip you know distance
a coherent lidar measures electric field
which is then proportional to 1 over R
okay so let's say range is a hundred
meters you want to see a hundred meters
the signal that a direct detection
lighter would receive would be
proportional to 1 over 100 squared
versus for coherent lidar is one over a
hundred so
coherent lidar would have 100 times a
stronger signal right so this one over R
versus 1 over r squared is the main
reason why coherent has much better SNR
typically than than direct detection
okay
so
um just to summarize so what type of
lidars are used in in in autonomy both
direct detection and coherent are used
today what's available you know on the
market most of it like again 90 of it is
is direct detection okay because it has
simpler Hardware simpler algorithms it's
just a a easier technology to develop so
that's what the market went after first
so it's mostly direct detection but
there are commercially available
coherent lidars also and it's gaining
more traction again it's it's a more
complex technology both in hardware and
in algorithms uh and and those
Technologies just naturally take a
little longer to catch up with the
market but uh as we go we are seeing
more and more you know coherent lidars
getting getting deployed and as I just
said they just have Superior performance
well a they have a very important
feature which is velocity information
estimation which directly section
doesn't even have but also even for for
for just for ranging coherent can can do
much better so if you get a you know
just a typical direct detection lidar
today that is the state of the art what
kind of performance can you expect from
it these are just some ballpark numbers
right don't take these numbers that as
you know set in stone just to give you
an idea of you know what what these
systems can do
some of them can see up to 400 meters
this is this is you know a kind of like
the very good ones to these the state of
the art average ones could see less than
200 meters 150 to 200 is is what an
average time of flight lighter or a
direct detection ladder can do range
resolution a few centimeters five to ten
centimeters is typical field of view for
instance the ones with rotating frame as
we know can do a full 360 degree
horizontal and vertically something
around 50 60 70 degrees is typical uh
they can achieve very good DOA
resolution like uh uh um you know 0.05
degrees is is kind of what a good ones
can can achieve some of them can do much
better than this but this is kind of
like what what you can get from a good
good one
um and then what's the measurement rate
10 to 30 Hertz most of them are around
10 Hertz today so you get 10 frames a
second and each frame can be like a full
360 degree scan of the environment so
one one map they can put out a lot of
points so millions of points per second
are the good ones today can do so say
if it can do one million points per
second at 10 Hertz it means each frame
has a hundred thousand points in it so
it gives you a point cloud with a
hundred thousand points with the full
360 field of view
um every 100 milliseconds which is
pretty impressive and the power
consumptions are you know a few tens of
Watts so these are what we can expect
so now we're going to look at the system
architecture of of direct detection
lighter first and then coherent lidar
and then afterwards we'll talk about
signal processing and you know how they
actually do range estimation velocity
estimation and DOA
okay let's start with direct detection
lidar so direct detection lidar here's a
system architecture for it so you start
with a laser Source this is kind of the
equivalent of the local oscillator in a
radar right it generates you know your
carrier and then it's fed to a optical
modulator for coherent lidar and
amplitude modulator is used amplitude
modulation because we need to
essentially modulate the power the
receiver is going to receive measure
power so amplitude modulation is kind of
like power modulation so you feed it
some waveform and that gets the the
laser gets amplitude modulated then it
goes through through the lens system
basically the TX Optics and then it goes
to the beam scanner and then at the
output you have this you know nicely
collimated laser beam that's getting
scanned and in in in
Azimuth and elevation and its amplitude
modulated so that's a transmit signal
model and then on the receive side what
we receive it's it's the same thing we
have seen in in sonar and radar so
there's some attenuation right there's
some DeLay So you get St of T minus Tau
and there is some Doppler shift e to the
J2 Pi FDT is a Doppler shift if there is
some relative radial velocity so you get
that uh through the the RX beam scanner
and then you pass it through the lens
system why do you need an RX beam
scanner because your TX and RX need to
look in the same direction right so you
need you need the same type of beam
scanning applied uh if for instance
especially if you have a this is a
biostatic system so we have a separate
transmit and receive Optics but they
need to look in the same direction
because if your transmission and
receiver looking at different directions
you wouldn't even see the echo that's
that's coming back so so they need to be
synchronously basically scanning if it's
a if it's a by Static system then a lens
system basically focuses the received
light into a photo detector and the
photo detector gives you an electrical
signal which we call call SPD pd4 photo
detector spdft and then you can digitize
that in the ADC take it to the the
digital domain and then on that you can
do range and doas estimation at the end
of the day you get our hat for range and
then Theta hat for a hat or the Azimuth
and elevation DOA okay now there's
variations of of this architectures
again so this is like a biostatic system
you can have monostatic system or it
might be a flash lidar so it wouldn't
have the beam scanner it would instead
have a diffuser and things like that but
but this basically covers the essential
components that go into or modules that
go into a direct detection lighter
system
okay so let's talk about I want to I
want to focus on on this part the photo
detection and develop the complete
signal model for this this electrical
signal that's coming out of the
photodiode we kind of have already done
it but I want to do it a little more you
know carefully so that we can we can
actually then talk about the DSP so for
direct detection it's uh it's it's
pretty uh simple so that that part of
the system some Optical incident and you
know Photon flux is coming in or the
power is p of T it's a function of time
again because we have amplitude
modulated the signal so so the receive
power varies the time
it goes to our pin photodiode and then
some photo current comes out which is
passed through a TIA and then that that
becomes the PD uh signal okay on the
left we have the picture so so you have
some Optics that's the lens and it
focuses the the incident light onto a a
uh the photo diode so so that big square
is basically the aperture of the active
aperture of the photodiode and we have
some incident uh
um basically power flux density which as
we know we denote by S average so that's
the pointing Vector the power flux
density of the incident light okay so
let's assume the photodiode is at Z
equal Z zero plane okay so it's
orthogonal to the axis of the prop beam
propagation that's to maximize uh
basically uh sensitivity and it's also
centered at zero zero in X Y
and they received electrical field
called that ERX of X Y and T on the on
the photodiode we can write that this is
this is this is what we get so Alpha is
again the attenuation factor and uh this
what we uh is is this e of X Y and Z
zero that's the electric field amplitude
and the on the photodiode plane right
then you have your delayed carrier right
e to the J 2 pi fct minus Tau that's
just basically the carrier or the
temporal part of the electric field that
is delayed by the round trip time of
flight uh you get S of T minus Tau
remember s of T was just the amplitude
modulation waveform that was applied so
that is also delayed by T minus Tau and
you have your Doppler term which is a e
to the J2 Pi f d t Okay so that's the
full basically electric field that is
incident on the photodiode okay now as
we know photodiode responds to power not
field so we should first calculate what
is the total power to calculate the
total power we first calculate the power
flux density which is our pointing
Vector as remember from the radar
discussion and the pointing Vector is
basically proportional to the amplitude
squared of the field right so it just
becomes minus one over two ETA uh ETA
remember is the is the impedance of free
space times magnitude squared of the
electric field and it's in in why the
negative sign here because the field is
going right to left here in the Z
Direction so that's why it's in Z hat
but with a minus sign just to get the
direction right that's why there's a
minus sign so s is a is a is a vector
field basically now as you square this
this field
um again as as we said uh the the phase
terms go away right so the square of e
to the J 2 pi f d t is one so this
disappears the square of e to the J 2 pi
FC T minus tau is also one so we
completely lose All Phase information
and we're just left with this which is
kind of like a the magnet the amplitude
of the of the flux density the only
thing that is time dependent is just
this s squared of T minus Tau so we are
just left with the square of the
waveform that we sent so this is the
power flux density in watts per meter is
a squared
to get the total power incident on the
photo detector we need to integrate this
across the photo detection
photosensitive area right so you just
integrate that pointing Vector over the
active photodiode area and that gives
you the total power integration is
pretty straightforward so so the total
incident power is just the integral of
the pointing Vector over the PD area and
we can just lump it into a constant and
say that that that integral is just some
P0 times the s s squared of T minus
style mind that the integral it's a
spatial integral right so it's
integrated over x y
on the active PD area so so that's why
this s squared of T minus Tau that just
comes out of the integral it has no XY
dependency and everything that is has x
y dependencies basically given here that
the actual integral is is just this
integral of e of x y z 0 squared times a
bunch of constant you have the alpha
squared and 2 ETA so you just do that
integral
and whatever comes out of it we are just
calling it P0 for us it's just a
constant it's just a power scale factor
basically the point is this photo
current that is coming out of the the PD
at the end of the day is just the
responsivity times
P of T the power and the power we just
showed that it's some p 0 times the
square of the waveform or the pulse
shape that was sent okay so we did all
this this derivation but this is really
the the signal model for the photo
current that that we now have and again
very important point is for direct
detection there is no phase information
there's no Doppler term in here right
it's just a intensity value so so
Doppler is lost we cannot measure
velocity with direct detection lighter
any questions
okay next step is this this current is
going to go through the Tia and get
converted to a voltage signal which we
call spdfd but we already know how to
model that it's a filtering effect right
so we said that the Tia is a low pass
filter
so you just pass that through your low
pass filter frequency response and this
is it so your your PD output
is just a Fourier inverse of the Tia
frequency response called that h of
Omega times the Fourier transform of
your photo photo current okay and again
in in a more uh you know simplified case
where uh if if if we go back to the
ideal Tia model with just the resistive
feedback RF and we also assume that PT
is is well within the bandwidth of the
Tif
right
um this this this filter output becomes
just as scaling as as we said so at the
end of the day the PD output
um in in in this simplified case just
becomes
um a scaled version of s squared and the
scale factor specifically is the
responsivity of the photodiode times the
feedback resistance of the Tia times
this P0 which is just the integral of
the squared electric field over the PD
area so that's just the power and times
s is squared
so so the signal is really some constant
times s squared of T minus Tau and this
is in volts and with this signal
we can now work on it and try to
estimate Tau that's what we want to
estimate that's our time of flight okay
again I want to retreat that Doppler
shift has no effect on the on the PD
signal in the case of direct detection
so because of that direct detection
lighters cannot estimate Target velocity
they can just find Tau because they
received signal only has tile dependency
it does not depend on anything else
so uh what types of so what is sft here
what type of uh waveforms or pulse
shapes uh is is used in and direct
detection lidar there's there's
different pulse shapes but typically
what systems do is they send very very
short pulses so the pulse durations are
on the order of three to ten nanoseconds
and here's is one example shown it's the
time axis is not in scale of course but
you basically have your carrier and your
amplitude modulated so you multiply it
by this s of T in this case the pulse
shape is a gaussian and that's a common
one that is used
it's like a nice smooth pulse shape and
then so they send these very short short
pulses and then
for some period after that they just
don't transmit anything and just wait
for Echoes again exactly like Paul cycle
sonar or or pulse radar there's some
pulse repetition interval or PRI that's
the time duration between two
consecutive pulses that are sent
and that duration basically determines
the maximum range uh that that the
system can detect because the maximum
round-trip delay Tau Max that can be
detected unambiguously is equal to that
pulse repetition interval if it's more
than that it's going to be confused with
the next pulse that that was sent so
that that PRI is that it's typically
microseconds like one to two
microseconds is what the the tri is so t
or the PRI is
is
one to two microseconds
um and and the pulse duration is
nanosecond so again this picture is not
not to scale the pulse is like super
super you know uh short and then most of
the time it's it's just not not
transmitting anything
um the peak power that they send these
systems is extremely high because they
have a very short time duration to send
they they max out the power within that
short time to get the best SNR so they
typically go up to right below the eye
safety limit or the MPE maximum
permissible emission limit so they send
very high power super short pulses
okay
uh questions
all right so this is now we have the
signal model
of full signal model and the system
architecture for
um uh direct detection lidar we're going
to talk about the coherent lidar next so
we understand both system architectures
and signal models and then we'll look at
how that these signals are processed to
arrange our velocity estimation so
here's the block diagram of a coherent
lidar
so coin lidar on the transmit side it's
it's kind of similar so you have a laser
source and it's kind of like your local
oscillator for for radar and then you
modulated with some waveform but here
instead of so for direct detection
amplitude modulation was applied for
coherent lidar you either phase or
frequency modulate right so you either
have FM or PM CW systems okay and it's a
CW so it's continuously sending
waveforms that are periodic and uh
coherent lidars almost always are
monostatic so they use the same you know
shared optics for for transmit and
receive and the reason for this is that
uh it's it's very tricky to make a
biostatic coherent lidar for reasons we
cannot quite get into the details of it
but it has to do with the physics of
coherent detection and speckle Optics uh
you you kind of to get good SNR you need
to make it a monostatic so basically
have the same Optical path for your
transmitted and received light and to
achieve that usually a beam splitter or
a circulator is is used so what this
device does is
um
it's a it's a photonic device which has
basically it's kind of like a
multiplexer so on the transmit side and
that's why we're showing this in in
different colors so this this if this
green is your outgoing beam transmit
beam most of it goes through the device
to the output Port there's going to be
some losses so this is just going
radiated out there's these devices have
a little bit of losses and
a small portion of the the outgoing or
the transmit signal also kind of spills
over to to the receive path okay so
that's kind of equivalent to the
spillover we have in radar where your
transmit antenna and receive antenna
couple directly this is the optical
equivalent of that so it's an
undesirable thing it's kind of like
additional noise but it just happens so
so that's your transmit path and then
under on the receive path the signal
that's that's coming back most of it
goes to the output Port of the device
there's a little bit of flosses
and also a little bit of leakage the
other way around but we don't care about
that so there's some Optical leakage or
spillover from on the receive path but
that that that this one is unimportant
so we don't even show it okay so that's
that's a beam splitter so uh physically
it has you know three three ports
basically and and so so two input ports
and one output Port but the output Port
is bi-directional right so physically
this is this is the output Port which
operates in a full duplex way light goes
both ways and then and and then it has
this input and and and that one that
goes to the to the coherent uh receiver
and and also again you have a you have a
beam scanner so you scan the beam
and then you transmit uh waveform is is
a signal is is uh the the waveform that
you're modulating times the carrier and
the receiver as we know is is is uh the
attenuation Factor times the delayed uh
waveform times the Doppler term e to the
J2 Pi F DT okay now I want to talk about
this this this uh module coherent
receiver because basically the magic all
the magic happens here and what this
this module does is it gives us an
electrical signal we call it scr cr4
coherent receiver scrft that is
proportional to the complex electric
field so that's the main distinction
between coherent lidar and direct
detection direct detection we showed
that we get a signal that is
proportional to the magnitude squared of
the field or the power in coherent lidar
we get a signal that is proportional to
the full electric field so
at a functional level what this coherent
receiver does and notice that it has two
inputs there's a received signal input
and there's a local oscillator input to
it so functionally it does this exact
same function as the down converter in
in radar did remember the radar down
converter we fed it the received signal
and the Lo signal right
and then it gave us this Sif of t
which was a complex signal
proportional to basically the full
complex field uh coherent receiver does
ex does the same function uh in in in
the optical domain and uh there is a
bunch of slides uh in the notes that
kind of go over the full detail of how
the coherent receiver works but here I
just want to go I don't want to go over
the full math because it's too detailed
for class but I want to go over the the
high level idea of of how you can
construct because inside it there are
still photo pi and photodiodes used and
Pim photo that we know it's like a
square detector it always gives you a
signal that's proportional to power so
how can you construct something with a
bunch of photodiodes that actually
extracts the field for you and that's
the magic of coherent detection the way
it's done is
um again I'm going to do sudo math here
so not you know all the terms are
correct but just to get you the idea if
you have just one photo dial okay and
instead of just feeding it the received
signal I I add another field to the
received signal and then I feed the sum
of the two to the photodiodes so I have
this ERX
and I also add some
a bit of the local oscillator ELO so I
add up the two Fields I couple them
together and then feed it to the photo
die what I'm going to get at the output
the current As We Know
is going to be proportional to the
magnitude squared of ERX plus ELO
right that's what the photodiode does so
so because the sum of two Fields I'm
going to get three terms out right so
I'm going to get ERX squared
is this readable I think it is right
okay ERX squared plus ELO squared
plus a cross term right which is plus 2
times the real part because these are
complex field of ERX times ELO star
conjugate of yellow okay so that's what
I get if I just use use one of these now
if I use a second photodiode
and to this one I feed instead of this
sum of the two fields that I subtract
them so I I do ERX minus ELO
I'm gonna clean this up minus yellow so
I subtract the two fields and and feed
it to that what photo current am I going
to get out of that so it's going to be
proportional to ERX minus yellow squared
so again I'm going to get three terms
there's going to be an ERX squared
plus ELO squared or magnitude squared
minus 2 times the real part of ERX
ELO conjugate
good
all right now somebody figured
they can do something pretty smart which
is if you put these two diodes back to
back
like so
so there's diode one diode two and again
one is we are feeding it ERX plus yellow
and to the second one we're repeating
ERX minus ELO and then you you look at
the current at this point this ID
is the is the difference of the currents
of the two diodes so this ID
is going to be id1 minus id2
and then the common modes cancel out so
the ERX cancels out the ELO squared
cancels out and it's going to be
proportional to just four times the real
part of ERX
ELO star
okay now we're getting somewhere ELO is
known so if you treat the ELO as just
like a constant this is going to be
proportional in a way to just the real
part of ERX
right
so by by using and this is called a
balance Detector by using one balanced
photo detector which is two photodiodes
back to back with these specific
combination of the two Fields applied to
it you can kind of extract the real part
of your input or receive the electric
field now you can make another balance
detector where you do the exact same
thing except you apply an Lo that is
Phase shifted by 90 degrees so you apply
J times yellow to it
that's just a 90 degree phase shift and
all that happens is that everywhere that
you have real part you get imaginary
part if you do the math so that one
gives you imaginary imaginary so then if
you if you do that second back to back
or balance detector and feed the the
face shift at the 90 degree phase shift
that Lo to it the the the the current
that you get out of that is going to be
proportional to the imaginary part of
ERX
so you covered the real part and the
imaginary part and then you just combine
them it's like a full IQ receiver at
that point for you okay again this was
sudo math uh the full correct math is is
in the notes but at the end of the day
this is what it looks like the the full
uh coherent IQ coherent receiver
this is the Full Construction so this
this uh module which is called a 90
degree Optical hybrid it's a passive
device it's like there's there's
waveguys and couplers And Delay lines in
it there's nothing active in there it's
just a passive device but you feed it a
local oscillator field and the receive
field and it generates at at its the
four outputs of it so it's two inputs
four outputs and the four outputs are
exactly what we talked about there's ERX
plus yellow ERX minus ELO ERX plus J
times yellow ERX minus J times yellow so
this you can do completely passively and
then you feed two of those to one
balance detector pass it through the Tia
and that gives you the imaginary part or
the is or the real part of your signal
or the eye component and then the other
two outputs go through another balance
detector and a TIA and that gives you
the imaginary part of of your
signal so a full signal model then for a
coherent lidar is is given by this this
what we call this scr output of the full
coherent receiver it's the in Phase plus
J times the quadrature component and if
you do the full math again it's it's in
the slides but we kind of like talked
about the high level idea behind it the
magic is that this signal that you get
out of your Korean receiver becomes
equal to just some constant call that
Kappa it's a multiplication of a bunch
of things responsivity feedback
resistance the power incident on the
diodes and so on and so forth so don't
mind about it's just a constant times
the delayed waveform s of T minus Tau
times the Doppler term e to the J so it
recovers the full complex waveform that
you had sent exactly like so if you go
back to your radar slides this is
exactly the signal model we had for Siff
T and radar right
it was exactly the same so now we
achieve the exact same you know signal
for Optics with Optics in lidar
which means now this is amazing because
everything we talked about in Radar Now
applies to lidar we can send the same
waveforms with coherent lidar chips or
or PN sequences we can apply the exact
same DSP so now you're already without
even talking about it you already know
what's going to come so we are going to
build an fmcw lidar and you're going to
do ffts to do ranging right and we're
going to do ffts to do velocity
estimation it's going to be the exact
same thing uh so so that's the magic of
of Korean lighter by the way this idea
of coherent receiver it's not new to
sensing it's been it's been done for for
many many years in Optical
Communications actually the entire
backbone of our internet relies on
optical coherent Optical transmission
and and and and and and
receivers so every data center they have
these coherent Optical receivers without
that actually it would have been
impossible to achieve the kind of data
bandwidths that we have today because
when you're able to transmit and receive
complex signals then it it opens up a
whole bunch of new possibilities for
modulation techniques and you know DSP
techniques
okay so that's a full signal model and
then as as we said
um the kind of waveforms that coherent
lidars transmit and receive uh they're
very similar to uh CW Radars so you can
have fmcw lidars which sends these
linear frequency chips and you can you
can build pmcw lidars which sends
ranging codes like M sequences or any
other type of codes digital codes with
good correlation properties basically
and then you phase modulate it
any questions yes
contrast media continues within the
lighter is scanning then like there will
be position shift exactly that's a good
question so the question is
you're transmitting
a continuous wave but also if either
physically like a spinning light or the
the the system is moving or even in a
scanning light or your mirrors are you
know routing or whatever the scanning
mechanism is it's pointing to different
directions so it turns out that because
so so then I guess the question is how
do we actually receive something if
you're moving
um so
exactly because of that that's one of
the big factors that limits how fast you
can move right so that's why part of the
reason these systems are limited to you
know 10 to 30 frames a second is because
if they move too fast like the faster
you move uh less Echo you're going to
receive because you're now looking in a
slightly different direction than where
you were pointing to so that's kind of
that and it's called the lag angle so
the lag angle is the angle or how much
you moved
um from the time you were transmitting
to the time the echo is coming back so
so so if that line lag angle is too
large so in a case of a scanning light
or let's say you have this scanning
mirror that is kind of like pivoting
like this uh so so you send a beam in
this direction and by the time the echo
is coming back your mirror has a
slightly moved so it's actually pointing
in a different direction right that
angle Theta is the lag angle
and uh
the larger it is a bigger SNR hit you're
gonna have
okay it can be it's not like as soon as
it becomes non-zero you lose everything
right because there's there's a bit of
you know angular field of view that
you're still receptive to but if if your
mirror is moving too fast so typically
if you plot you know SNR
versus the lag angle Theta
um it's usually you know nice and
constant and then there's a cliff that
it that it drops and that kind of limits
you know how fast how fast you can scan
or move or whatever your beam scanning
technique is so that's a that's a very
good question that's a it's a it's a
design factor that you need to model it
study it and kind of determines
um how how fast you can move and it's
different uh the the lag effect is
actually different between coherent
lidar and and direct detection letter
actually turns out that for direct food
direct detection it's easy to to find
that curve for coherent it becomes
doable but very complicated you need to
like go into the very details of the
speckle physics and things like that
okay so now we're ready to talk about
algorithms
uh that are used to do first we will
talk about the direct detection lidar
which is is just ranging right and then
we'll talk about the the coherent
lighter which does range and Doppler
before that I want to show a a quick
live demo so uh we have a lidar here
this is a
direct detection lidar with a rotating
frame so it's a multi-beam rotating
frame lighter actually you don't see the
rotation because the mechanical motor is
behind this IR transparent glass so
inside this actually from where you are
you probably don't hear it but I can
hear it spinning there's a motor
spinning in there it's spinning at 10
Hertz and it has 32 laser beams that
it's basically transmitting and and it's
constantly rotating so let's look at it
it's it's running
if
I don't break it I we should be able to
okay I think it's working
so I'm just gonna
switch to that
so here's the view of the classroom full
360. you actually see the
the
HDMI is not okay
so you kind of see the shadow of me and
that's that's the wall
um and and this is a full
you know uh 3D view you see the scan
lines and the coloring is by uh
reflectivity so the walls are more
reflective
if anyone wants to do a tick tock dance
or something uh uh Now's the Time
so um yeah so so so you see the scan
lines on the wall so it's that's the the
you know the rotating beams colors
reflectivity so walls are apparently
more reflective at the 905 wavelengths
that this is operating at and the fabric
on the on the chairs is is a little a
little less reflective also on the top
this kind of like panoramic view is that
they actually unroll the point cloud and
make it like a very wide image IR image
basically
um so so yeah that's uh that's it
uh you had something
they reflective at some point what was
it was it metal or something something
that showed red uh yeah so that's your
laptop which is more more IR reflective
apparently and actually if you change
the angle you should see the there you
go you see the the reflectivity changes
I'm going to just zoom in on that and
see that's the angle of incidence so so
because these are diffuse reflectors
there's the cosine Theta term that that
this goes with the angle so if you point
it exactly towards this that's where you
get maximum signal and when it becomes
red you're basically perfectly pointing
towards it anyway this is this is fun
but we need to get back to the lecture I
think yeah you get an idea I mean this
is not the best slider out there but
it's better than average I mean it's
it's a good lighter this one sees up to
150 meters or so
um 200 meters if for very you know
strong reflective targets but on average
100 to 150 meters it's pretty useful you
see this is like a your live mapping
essentially the the full the full
classroom okay
um
I think any requests on this before we
go back to okay let's go back to the
slides okay so let's talk about how
range estimation is done for direct
detection lighter so as we said these
systems essentially do time division
multiplexing or TDM so they just
repeatedly send out these short pulses
and then they wait for some time which
is a pulse repetition interval tpri
before meeting the next one so the
maximum round trip delay they can
measure is equal to tpri and that also
determines the maximum range they can
measure so the maximum range is going to
be speed of light times Tau Max over 2
which becomes speed of light times the
pulse repetition interval over two or
you can invert that and say how many
points per second they can measure that
becomes C over to R Max so that's the
number of range measurements per second
in terms of the ranging algorithms again
it's exactly like Paul cycle of sonar or
pulse radar so you can do simple
thresholding or match filtering right
almost all systems I know of do
thresholding because it works really
well for for lighter because the pulses
are so short remember for sonar there
was this this effect of you know the
bias and which made thresholding kind of
uh not not a good technique for lidar
it's actually pretty good uh and and
that's and because of the Simplicity of
it that's what most systems uh use and
again pulse shapes can be different but
gaussian is is a standard one but in
principle you can do match filtering
with with coded waveforms things like
Barca codes and things like that to to
improve your your sensitivity
um and also another thing that makes a
threshold-based ranging very attractive
because it's a simple threshold detector
you don't care about distorting the
waveform so then you can operate with
apds or spats and get really good
sensitivity actually the slider we just
looked at it uses spats for for
detecting the the pulses uh okay so how
does it how does it work very simple
it's called Leading Edge ranging which
is a fancy term for for thresholding so
you have some transmitted pulse shown in
green here note that we are plotting s
squared a square of the waveform right
because our signal model showed that
what we receive is proportional to the
square of the of the pulse shape that we
send so as a square root of T that's the
transmitted pulse it's normalized to one
okay and then the the time it crosses
half the maximum which is 0.5 uh the the
system marks that or kind of you know
records that I call that Tau 0 and then
what you receive is is some attenuated
and delayed version of s squared right
so so that's shown in in blue here so it
goes up to some s s Max and that's the
the pulse shape and then it also finds
the point of half maximum for the
receive one to call that Tau sub e and
then if you just subtract the two it
gives you the the round trip delay and
then range is just c times Tau over 2.
so extremely simple you know it's it's
as easy as it gets uh for for ranging
and actually works pretty well I mean we
just saw an example of it this system is
is doing uh I assume I mean I don't know
all the details maybe they're doing
something a little fancier but I would
be surprised if they did something much
fancier than this uh now here what we're
showing we are showing you know the full
continuous time waveforms but in
practice we know signals are sampled
right so we need to work with the
digitized version of the received signal
so so uh usually you set your sampling
rate high enough that you get a few
samples on the full pulse shape
three four five or so
um and then your sampling rate the ADC
sampling rate F sub s which is 1 over
the sampling interval that determines
your ranging resolution because the
minimum uh time Delta that you can
measure that Delta Tau Min is equal to
the sampling interval of your ADC you
can just go one sample extra and that
determines your Delta R Delta range
between you know two two consecutive
ranges that you can measure so it just
becomes a speed of light times the
sampling interval over two that's your
range resolution for the simple Leading
Edge now as I said
um in in principle you work with a A
discretized or digitized Echo waveform
okay and that introduces some additional
error in your in your in your time
estimation because if if you just work
with these discrete samples that are
shown here so uh you you find the
maximum one and then that's your best
guess of what the peak was and then you
typically don't get a sample exactly at
half of it so you just pick the closest
sample to the half Max and call that you
know your Leading Edge which is not the
exact Leading Edge of the continuous
time waveform so so the Tau e that you
get would have some additional error due
to digitization but some fancier systems
actually can make this more accurate in
DSP by doing a fit to the samples
because you know the exact waveform that
you send Save was a gaussian so you can
take these samples and basically fit a
gaussian to it
as it's shown down here and then from
that and you can do that you know as
finely as you you want in DSP and and
then you find the the Leading Edge which
is the half Max on the on the fit and
and and that basically makes it more
accurate
in many robotic applications you
typically don't care about you know that
level of accuracy from just the pure
discretized waveforms you can get like
five to ten centimeters and that's
usually good enough but in other
applications
you might need much more accurate
ranging and this is a technique that
that can that can help you in those
situations
another thing that can happen in in
practice is uh you can get multiple
Echoes from a single laser beam okay it
doesn't happen often most of the time
like 90 something percent of the uh
pulses that you send out they just Echo
back from just one Target because these
are very narrow laser beams but certain
cases so here's one example so we sent
out the laser beam it's going through
you know the the the the the the
windshield of a car and that can
generate some partial you know uh Echoes
at the entry point at the exit point
then it goes through some you know
vegetation the leaves of the tree and
they can partially overlap the the the
the you know the gaussian beam and you
get some Echoes from those and it
finally hits a wall and that's kind of
like the the rest of the the the signal
Echoes back so if you look at you know
your full received Echo waveform it can
have you know in this case one two three
four five little Echoes from different
different parts of the scene this is
kind of an extreme example in reality
again most of the time like 95 of the
the cases you just get one Echo and then
the other five you can have one extra
maybe one or two extras but some wider
systems
uh do report more than one Echo per per
transmitted pulse right uh typically
they report two or three
um and it doesn't mean that like if when
they report three all three are true
positive some of them might be false
positive as we know maybe it's from fog
or or maybe it's just noise or something
like that but they do report those and
then it's up to the user to decide you
know which ones are real targets and
which ones are not and it's not always
obvious again this one we just looked at
it returns two Echoes and and you can
display both or or just one I was just
displaying the main one the strong one
but you can he can look at both
okay
um questions
all right that's uh that's it about so
coherent uh direct detection lighter
says easy as that uh basically you just
take your signal uh take your Echo
digitize it find the Leading Edge and
then convert that time to to range and
then you get range okay DOA we'll talk
about later
um but before that uh we're going to
talk about range and Doppler estimation
for coherent lidar so this is going to
need a bit of DSP as as you can imagine
because uh it has phase information in
it uh but um I'm just going to set it up
and then we will talk about the details
next time but uh again as we said
coherent lighters continuously transmit
uh uh uh waveforms that are periodic
very similar to CM CW radar so so they
can they can transmit frequency chirps
like and that makes an fmcw lidar or
they can transmit ranging codes like
prns and that makes APM CW lighter as
far as I know no
pmcw lighters are commercially deployed
today anything that's commercially out
there and available is fmcw lidar
um but in research people are working on
it in principle it works and it has even
some advantages over uh the fmcw lineup
but for the same reason in radar almost
all the deployed CW Radars for autonomy
are fmcw there's very little pmcw radar
Lloyd same for for light are those some
added complexity in hardware and um
algorithms that just makes it a little
more difficult to develop signal
processing algorithms for coherent lidar
again are very similar to those for
radar because why are they very similar
because the signal model is exact same
right same signal same processing we're
estimating the same parameters with the
same signal model so they're going to be
very similar but there are some key
differences one is the fact that uh
lidar beams are much much narrower than
radar right so you're working with these
millimeter
thin laser beams versus radar you can
have almost isotropic beam patterns this
is a good thing so it makes lidar DSP
easier because you can almost assume
always I I'm just looking for one Target
in this in this signal versus in radar
we had to you know superimpose and
assume multiple targets and then do C4
and other things to kind of like
separate them from the noise in lidar
this helps but there's another effect
which makes slides are slightly more
tricky and that's the fact that the
Doppler shifts that you see in lidar the
Doppler frequencies that that you see in
in lidar are much much higher than radar
by many orders by by almost like three
orders of magnitude or more because
Doppler shifts are inversely
proportional to wavelengths if you
remember and lidar operates at much
shorter wavelengths so for the same
velocity of the target order for the
same relative velocity the Doppler shift
that you see in a lidar is significantly
higher than radar and if you remember
from radar DSP we actually use the fact
that Doppler shifts are small to
simplify our DSP we kind of set for the
duration of a tube we kind of ignore
Doppler and only use you know the phase
shifts in between consecutive chips in
fmcw radar to estimate Doppler as we'll
see you cannot make that assumption in
lidar because the again the Doppler
shifts are much much larger and non
negligible even within a one chip but
there turns out that there's a very
clever technique to actually solve that
which we'll talk about next time